moi j'étais assis aussi ici
tranquillement puis le feu on commence à
avoir le feu la bonne
corinne cambell et la centaine
d'habitants du petit village de lauwe
mcdonald's dans les montagnes du
nord-ouest de sydney l'ont échappé belle
c'est ici que les feux de forêt
australiens ont commencé il ya deux mois
elle et sa fille ont eu la peur de leur
vie
le problème c'est que c'est comme
derrière la montagne et on est couverte
de fumée est en fait ce qui fait peur
c'est qu'on sait pas d'où ça vient
exactement ça montre tous les feux qui
ont brûlé
autour de moi l'application find you me
l'avait averti qu' d incendie avait
éclaté près de chez elle avec toutes les
informations nécessaires direction du
vent et surtout quoi faire dans des
situations précises ce qu'un quand le
ciel commençait à tomber de les feuilles
comme ça complètement brûlé sa tombe est
partout c'est là que j'ai commencé à
m'inquiéter un moment donné il disait
faut se préparer et on avait le choix
entre essayer de sauver la maison ou de
partir moi comme je peux me sauvé par la
rivière 6 parce que j'ai un bateau la
rivière juste en bas il que si mme sauvé
par voiture j'avais les deux prêts à
partir donc moi j'avais décidé de rester
pour sauver la maison les pompiers
volontaires locaux sont parvenus à
contenir les incendies en brûlant les
broussailles autour des zones habitées
pour empêcher le feu de se propager les
foyers principaux incendies étaient
inaccessibles et seuls des hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau ont pu en venir à bout
cette application est utilisé en ce
moment même partout en australie
c'est vraiment vraiment génial c'est pas
parfait parce que des fois ils n'ont pas
le temps de changer les gens défaut est
un petit peu frustré mais il y avait
tellement de feu en même temps moi je
comprends mais c'était ça c'est m
qui sauve des vies je comptais vraiment
dessus parce qu'on peut pas voir où sont
les feux ont complètement couvert 1 là
bas tout est ici prêt à partir pour le
moment tout est sous contrôle mais le
danger reste élevé maintenant ça me dis
donc si j'ai la mecque dans n'ont qu'eux
y'a encore des feux qui sont actifs dans
la région tout va changer si comme on le
pense les températures remontent dans
les 40 degrés avec du vent et la fin des
averses
jean michel leprince sera du canada lors
au mcdonald's dans l'état des nouvelles
galles du sud